good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
the number of covid19 cases may be
starting to gradually slow down
but for paramedics there's no let up in
the pressures they're facing
sky news has spent 48 hours on the front
line with the welsh ambulance service
and while its staff are still treating
people with the virus they're also
having to deal
with increasing numbers of patients who
are finding the pandemic has affected
their mental health
this from tom parmenter his special
report
everyone has had enough
but they just keep going
the covered cases are gradually slowing
down
but the next wave in north wales is this
when she's been found collapsed in the
streets she is possibly an overdose
really sadly it sounds like she's lost
her dad to cover quite recently which is
probably
really brought her to this state that
she's in now
[Music]
when we get to the milor hospital in
wrexham the patient refuses to go in
there's now something of a gentle
standoff between the security
at the hospital here and the paramedics
and the patient who just doesn't want to
go inside it's
a difficult delicate job that they have
after almost an hour she's guided in for
specialist
care her family member had passed away
last night we covered and just unable to
cope with the situation at the moment
really
and it's on every shift sometimes for
the full
12 hours some shifts we we can see
um every patient will have some element
of mental health whether that was the
primary reason for the call
or not and that makes it really
challenging for us because we have
limited
ways of dealing with these things other
than a e they're still picking up covid
patients every day
but slowly the winter tide is receding
shirley had it in january and still
isn't right
she now has chest pains to know that you
can't go anywhere it's just
you know and you're just there on your
own and it's you can see why people do
go
you know go off the red because
it's just there's nothing you can do is
you can't go nowhere you can't
can't do anything if you notice
this is where the vast majority of
people find help
with the one one one call team our
straightforward symptoms of what we
perceived as straightforward calls to us
previously like your sore throats even
those type of calls now are coming in
with
some level of mental health issues you
know patients are really anxious
um really scared so again this is the
the benefit of this service is that we
can actually
help and advise those patients this
isn't unique to wales but they are
responding here
so we're certainly looking to enhance
what we can do here in wales
certainly in the ambulance service to
support mental health patients and i
expect to see
more specialist mental health services
within the adwords service in the next
12 months
after every covert job every item on
these vehicles is deep
cleaned you can get rid of coronavirus
doing this you can't wipe away its side
effects
tom parmenter sky news north wales
and if you're affected by any of the
issues mentioned in that report
samaritans is available 24 7. you can
call them on 116 123
or email joe at samaritans.org those
contact details on the bottom of your
screen
now and if you can see a longer version
of that report at these times
here on sky news
the chancellor is warning britain's
public finances will face enormous
strains in the wake of the latest
lockdown
rishi sunak is expected to include a
host of actions to kick-start the
economy in wednesday's budget
including a mortgage guarantee scheme to
help aspiring homeowners
but he'll also emphasize the need to
start paying back the billions borrowed
for the pandemic political correspondent
rob powell joins me now from
westminster so some good news uh in the
budget to come but also some bad news as
well
yeah and i think we're probably jillian
getting the good news or some of the
good news at least uh this morning with
a flurry of announcements from the
treasury about what we should expect in
the
uh big annual financial statement
from the chancellor on wednesday this
mortgage guarantee scheme which will
run from april essentially will
allow 95 mortgages so mortgages where
people don't have to put
as much cash up front as a deposit they
vanish from the market during the
pandemic the government wants to get
them back they will be available
up to 600 000 pounds a scheme
similar but not exactly the same as the
help to buy scheme that has run
in previous years there's also announced
an announcement today about added
flexibility
being put into traineeship and
apprenticeship schemes with some extra
money as well
also news about a fast track visa for
certain companies too so the chancellor
i think will want to
talk about the good side
of um what's to come about boosting the
economy
and about measures he's going to put in
place to do that but i think the main
meat of the budget is still going to be
around the pandemic and that's what he's
getting at in his interview with the
financial times
overnight talking about how there will
be more help to come i think what that
means in practice is potentially
extensions of things like the furlough
scheme maybe the business
rate relief as well and potentially an
extension of the universal credit
uplift but rishi sunak also saying that
he will
need to level with the public about how
they are going to put public finances
back on a stable footing and i think
essentially what that means
is perhaps we will get an indication if
not an immediate imposition
of tax rises rob thank you
police and military in northern nigeria
have launched a rescue operation after
317 girls were kidnapped at gunpoint
from a boarding school
the nigerian president muhammadu buhari
has said his government won't give in to
blackmail
it's the latest in a series of student
abductions in the country
melanovilinovich reports it's a place
where they should have been safe
but more than 300 girls were abducted
from their boarding school in northwest
nigeria
taken from their dormitories at night
among them were eunice mohammed's four
daughters
tell me the situation we tried to come
by that time
exchanging fire between that
large groups of armed men operate in
this area
they kidnap for ransom a nigerian police
and army say
they are now hunting them we're on the
trail of the kidnappers that's why you
find us
in the fringes of the forest here it's
part of our locational effort
and it's part of our coding cordoning
efforts
it's been nearly eight years since the
terror group boko haram abducted 276
schoolgirls
causing global outrage more than a
hundred of them
never returned home and since then
schools have become common targets
for mass kidnappings
just last week 42 people including 27
pupils
were taken from a science college in
niger state
and in december 344 boys were abducted
from a secondary school in northern
katsina state
they were later released but aid
agencies say that the situation is
deteriorating
people are getting used to being able to
undertake something like this the
horrific consequences of not only being
taken
now but the consequences are compounded
by the fact that the parents might not
send their girls back to school if
they're released
and other parents might withdraw their
girls from school
for families of missing girls an
agonizing wade begins in the hope
of getting their daughters back milena
vasselinovich
sky news tiger woods's family have
issued an update on his condition after
he was involved in a car crash in l.a
they say he's had to undergo follow-up
procedures after surgery for two open
fractures and a shattered ankle
following the accident earlier this week
the 15-time major champion is said to be
in good spirits
it's not yet known whether his injuries
will mean an end to his golfing career
lady gaga's two french bulldogs have
been found safe
and unharmed after being stolen at
gunpoint two days ago
the pop star had offered a half a
million dollar reward for their return
after her dog walker ryan fisher was
shot in hollywood on wednesday
he's expected to make a full recovery
cctv footage has captured the moment a
woman was dragged by a car down a street
in california
after her purse was stolen the incident
follows a series of attacks and
robberies against people of asian
descent in the san francisco bay area
police say the robbery is under
investigation
a second world war era plane will saw
over captain sir tom moore's funeral
service later today in honor of the
veteran
sir tom who raised more than 32 million
pounds for nhs charities died at bedford
hospital earlier this month
at the age of 100 shortly after testing
positive for
covid19 british army officers have
volunteered to mentor nhs leaders to
help them respond to the pandemic
more than 130 members of nhs england
have been given advice on leadership
dealing with uncertainty decision making
and planning under pressure
lieutenant colonel joanna muntz is a
british army officer at sandhurst who
helped develop the mentoring programme
she joins us now from tidworth in
wiltshire good morning to you
first of all where did the idea for this
mentoring scheme
come from what were you approached
initially yeah so if i just might start
by
saying that from my own perspective and
on behalf of the mentors
involved it's been an absolute privilege
to be able to support
um such dedicated capable and
hardworking nhs
leaders throughout this challenging time
i think it was probably
march last year when we were all just
beginning to acknowledge the enormity of
this crisis
when the nhs started to think of ways in
which they might best support their
leaders through this
and given the army's reputation for
operating under crisis situations and
our reputation for excellent leadership
the nhs reached out to us to see what we
might be able to offer in support
obviously we were humbled as an
organization to be approached and
delighted that we could assist
how exactly has the the mentoring
project been been working
so um we've had um
army leaders volunteer from around the
world
wherever they're based and they have
been providing leadership
leading through crisis mentorship to nhs
leaders and that has spanned the ranks
um
from the executive level lieutenant
general within the army
mentoring the nhs most senior leaders
through to our middle management
um our most senior soldiers our
regimental assault majors
managing their equivalents in the nhs
and what would you say has been the
benefit of this scheme what sort of
results
have you seen so the feedback through
the mentors has suggested that
um not only of the nhs benefited from
this program but the
army mentors have found it incredibly
value valuable too um
from the nhs individual perspective
they've reported back that they've
had increased self-awareness so that's
the awareness
of their how their leadership style
affects the team around them
they've reported back that they've had
improved confidence um
and not least really the sessions have
provided them the confidential space
to really um get to the bottom of their
issues and really reflect on their
priorities which has enabled them to
create a plan going forward and also the
mentors have offered
a sounding board a listening ear and
just enabled the mentees to
unburden their day obviously this has
come about because of the pandemic and
has been seen as a way
to help nhs staff through the pandemic
but do you see it as something that
might
continue um i think
that um absolutely the amount that we
can learn
from other government other government
departments and other organizations
is endless and i think it's been really
valuable for both the nhs and the army
to understand a bit more about each
other's organization um
throughout this mentoring program and i
think that we
will learn from that that it's a really
valuable thing to do
and no doubt personal bonds will have
been uh formed and
friendships um forged from this this
situation
absolutely i've had um senior army
officers that have
been leaving the army during the course
of the program and have been in touch
with me to say
is it okay to keep this mentoring
relationship going and absolutely on a
personal level that's fine
okay looking forward to that continued
relationship
uh and uh we thank you for your service
and all the help that you've been
offering
to the nhs through this pandemic
lieutenant colonel joanna muntz thank
you
a restaurant in new york has come up
with a novel way to make the dining
experience a little less lonely as covid
restrictions remain in place
brooklyn's famous peter lugar steakhouse
has borrowed figures from the local
madame tussauds to fill
the two-thirds of the indoor space still
unavailable to customers
so diners can now sit with audrey
hepburn
and enjoy breakfast at tiffany so we'll
have a drink next to everyone's favorite
ad executive
don draper also known as john hamm from
mad men
who would you want to sit next isabel
stephen dixon that's no good you can sit
next to him anytime he might be watching
are you watching is he watching
probably um weather-wise
it's lovely lots of sunshine today it's
a beautiful beautiful morning it's cold
out there though
let's take a look
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
it's coldest in the south this morning
where we've had clear skies overnight
minus four in oxford but it's
beautifully sunny just a little bit of
mist and fog in the southwest that
shouldn't take too long to lift
northwestern areas though we've got this
weak front that's giving some drizzly
rain across parts of
donegal through northern ireland into
south west and western scotland this
area of cloud here
will push a little bit further south
through the day into northern areas of
the irish sea
maybe uh southeast scotland perhaps
cumbria but i don't think it'll amount
to much it'll just bring some cloudier
weather southwards
skies then brightening up further north
and as you can see for the majority of
us though it is fine
dry and sunny with temperatures up to
about 10 to 13 degrees
not bad at all where you keep clear
skies tonight there'll be a frost again
but i think there'll be a bit more in
the way of cloud
mist and fog still fed extensive cloud
aware that old front lines
and a bit more in the way of fog around
more eastern and south eastern coast so
it could be great with you first thing
then again sunshine becomes more
widespread a lovely sunday
more in the way of cloud though by
monday
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come jamie will have all your
sport for you morning i still get
sunshine but
it is very nice had the shorts and
t-shirt on yesterday ice cream
we don't need to know that that's the
irishman for you the second the sun
comes out short t-shirt ice cream
um but if you want a break from the
lovely sunshine there's lots of sport
you can sit indoors and watch today
including the six nations rugby it's
back this weekend not for scottish fans
mind you
their trip to france tomorrow is off
after a coveted outbreak in the home
squad
england's match with wales though does
go ahead in cardiff but can
england cope with this man courtney laws
will be hearing from both head coaches
and they are just relentless at the
moment manchester city can they make it
20
successive wins in all competitions this
lunch time we're looking ahead to their
match against west ham
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
boy we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
good morning it's 7 30 you're watching
sky news breakfast
the number of kovid 19 cases may be
starting to gradually slow down
but for paramedics there's no let up in
the pressures they're facing
sky news spent 48 hours on the front
line with ambulance staff in north wales
and while they were still treating
people with the virus they're also
having to deal with increasing numbers
of patients bearing
mental scars from the pandemic this is
tom parmenter's special report
golf three zero zero good morning
another 12 hour shift
they're picking up the victims of the
virus and the victims of lockdown
shirley had covered in january now her
daughter has had to call for help again
she's got pains in her chest um
but we'll see what we'll see what they
say hopefully should be all right
and if so kobe is still with us his name
is kind of he wants to do one now
does it be edited to know that you can't
go anywhere it's just
you know and you're just there on your
own and it's you see why people do go
you know go off the red because it's
just there's nothing you can do is you
can't go nowhere you can't
you can't do anything my name's kiera
mcclelland i'm a paramedic in wrexham
hamlet station
i'm vicky moran i'm a emergency medical
technician for
welsh chamberlain service and i'm based
in maxson station i've not really known
much different i'm only 18 months into
the
role and there's colleagues of 30 odd
years who are saying it's
the most challenging time they've ever
seen and they're struggling and
questioning their question their roles
i've never seen so many poorly patients
in a small amount of time
i think that will take its toll on
anybody never mind
paramedic it's harder for family because
family um
will be about me they will be about me
more than i will be about myself
and so i think that's what you find hard
is you know they'll ask you know have
you had covered jobs today
well yeah we get code for jobs nearly
every day
and so yeah they they do worry family do
worry
the house is currently declared as a
redstone due to
the red level ppe it
even though the patient they're seeing
has previously tested negative for
covid19
there are other residents here who are
positive and so everything moves up a
level
these coved jobs are thankfully slowing
down
but this isn't she's been found
collapsed in the streets she is possibly
an overdose
really sadly it sounds like she's lost
her dad to cover quite recently which is
probably
really brought her to this state that
she's in now
[Music]
when we get to the myler hospital in
wrexham the patient refuses to go in
there's now something of a gentle
standoff between the security
at the hospital here and the paramedics
and the patient who just doesn't want to
go inside it's
a difficult delicate job that they have
after almost an hour she's guided in for
specialist care
her family member had passed away last
night recovered
and just unable to cope with the
situation at the moment really
and it's on every shift sometimes for
the full
12 hours some shifts we can see
um every patient will have some element
of mental health whether that was the
primary reason for the call
or not and that makes it really
challenging for us because we have
limited
ways of dealing with these things other
than a e they're equally limited they
see medical patients
on top of those mental health patients
so they have to weigh up
the priority if there's no main medical
concern
it's purely a wait for the mental health
teams here and there's not enough staff
unfortunately
in the queue at the miler hospital are
soldiers
helping out on ambulances they've been
on deployment since
christmas we're not illegals or nothing
like that we're just here to help
that's it i was opening my eyes quite a
lot because obviously you didn't think
it was as bad as it was
but when you when you're on there and
your ambulances go to these houses
seeing the people seeing what's done to
them
you think yeah that's quite bad if you
notice that your [ __ ] is becoming
really really short of breath and this
is where the vast majority of people
find help
with the one one one call team our
straightforward symptoms of what we
perceived as straightforward calls to us
previously like your sore throats even
those type of calls now are coming in
with
some level of mental health issues you
know patients are really anxious
um really scared so again this is the
the benefit of this service is that we
can actually help and advise those
patients
he did state that he's normally fit and
well okay he's just concerned about
culture
there is an impact on the nation there
with the mental health and everything is
going on and
you know services have adapted out there
but i think one of the biggest
challenges is
basically looking after the staff as
well as doing everything else making
sure that the staff are okay
the next job is claire who's collapsed
at home with very low blood pressure
it's linked to a pre-existing condition
a very stressful year to be honest
yeah and i work in the wedding industry
and we've had such a tough year and the
stress that we've all been under with
transferring thousands of weddings but
obviously there's a road map out of it
now so hopefully
the stress is going to go away
claire is still coping but many more
people of all ages
are not and so this service needs to
adapt
we're certainly looking to enhance what
we can do here in wales certainly in the
ambulance service to support mental
health patients and i expect to see
more specialist mental health services
within the adwords service in the next
12 months
yeah roger thanks um we'll make our way
back to base
thank you when kieran and vicky finish
marl and andy are in full flow every
single item on board is cleaned
after a covered patient we don't get to
know
what equipment has been used on the
vehicle or what medication has been used
so but all i know that it may have been
opened and something may have been taken
out of this box during the treatment but
i'm not aware
so better safe than sorry you clean
everything
if it's on this kit you can wipe
coronavirus away
but it's side effects run deep and need
just as much care
tom parmenter sky news north wales
and if you've been affected by any of
the issues mentioned in that report
samaritans is available
24 7. you can call them on 116 123
or email joe samaritans.org those
contact details on the bottom of your
screen now
and if you want to watch the full report
it'll be playing throughout the day on
sky news the times are listed
on your screen
president biden says he will be holding
saudi arabia's crown prince to account
for human rights abuses after u.s
intelligence services accused him
of approving an operation to kill the
saudi journalist and dissident jamal
khashoggi
he's believed to have been murdered and
dismembered at saudi arabia's embassy in
istanbul in 2018.
the saudi foreign ministry has rejected
the report's finding our defense and
security correspondent aleister bunkel
reports from washington
it was long awaited but as expected the
cia believes that saudi arabia's crown
prince
mohammed bin salman did authorize the
killing of journalist jamal khashoggi
in a short four-page executive summary
the intelligence agency said that it
based its assessment on
the crown prince's control of
decision-making in the kingdom
the direct involvement of a key advisor
and members of muhammad bin salman's
protective detail in the operation
and the crown prince's support for using
violent measures
to silence dissidents abroad including
khashoggi what's your reaction to the
report
it's a historic moment this
uh and makes it quite clear that it
leads right to the top to the to the
crown prince
uh ordering and approving this uh
horrific
operation jamal khashoggi went to the
saudi consulate
in istanbul on october the 2nd 2018
to pick up papers allowing him to wed
his turkish fiance
as she waited for him outside he was
ambushed
tortured and killed inside
initially saudi arabia denied any
knowledge of his disappearance
then finally admitted he had died in a
fight
mohammed bin salman said that he took
personal responsibility
but had no knowledge of the killing the
biden administration has announced
financial and visa sanctions with the
state department banning
76 saudis from entering america
but not mohammed bin salman i spoke
yesterday with the king
not the prince made it clear to him that
the rules are changing
and we're going to be announcing
significant changes today and on monday
we are going to hold them accountable
for human rights abuses
the saudi government has rejected the
report as
negative false and unacceptable
the relationship with with saudi arabia
is an important one
we have significant uh ongoing interests
we remain committed to
the defense of the kingdom uh
but we also want to make sure and this
is what the president has said from the
outset
that the relationship better reflects
our interests
and our values president biden
isn't taking any specific action against
mohammed bin salman
that will be controversial for some but
the white house is calculating
that the very release of this report
will be humiliation enough
for saudi arabia's young crown prince
alas the bunker sky news washington
time now to see what the weather's going
to do to us today with isabel
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello good morning so nice not to have
any weather warnings we've got high
pressure in charge which is keeping
things dry and settled for most
having said that there is a weak front
that's giving cloudy skies to ireland
northern ireland and up into south west
and central scotland there is some
drizzly rain on this this morning and
that cloud will tend to come and go a
little probably drifting a little
further southwards during the day
otherwise though early fog which is very
extensive at the moment across the west
country
will clear and there'll be plenty of
sunshine lots of blue sky
to enjoy today temperatures up to about
10 to 13 celsius that's 55 fahrenheit a
few degrees above average
for this time of year now as we head
through this evening tonight the cloud
becomes a little more extensive across
these
central and northwestern areas a bit
more in the way of mist and fog maybe
some fog as well running
through the thames estuary for tomorrow
morning so you might well wake up
tomorrow morning it's pretty gray and
cold with you but then that fog should
lift and the cloud
should tend to thin a little bit and
again for many it's a fine day quite
breezy mind you
for the south coast bear in mind monday
will be a little different brightest in
the west
cloudier and cooler in the east
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
welcome back uh back with us to take us
through the morning's newspapers the
journalist and broadcaster podesha and
the comedian
andrew doyle welcome back to you both
starting with the express badisha
and this story um talking about
president biden's first
military action that's been carried out
yeah i don't really appreciate the rambo
reference in the in the title because it
seems to lionize that kind of
militarization which actually joe biden
gained the election by saying he wasn't
like that so it's interesting that this
small piece of news is shelved away on
page
13. uh american military personnel
have bombed some fighting units in syria
that were used by fighters backed by
iran killing 22 fighters and this
is what they term a sort of small
measured reciprocation
of an attack that happened at a u.s
air base close to erbil airport which
killed
one contract worker the reason i picked
up the story is
that for the last year or so we've been
so consumed talking about
the pandemic and all the things we've
lost in our inconveniences but we forget
that
there are multiple countries all over
the world particularly syria but there
are many other examples that have been
under a war or a siege or a fragile
state situation
for years now we're edging into
something like year eight
of these conflicts not to mention all
the fragile states that follow
wars and conflicts anyway so the things
that we in the uk have been scared of
losing
civil society social fabric education
for the young
schooling that you can rely on have
actually all been lost by people in
syria and in many many other countries
it's also interesting that joe biden
really just became president and this is
one of the first things he does a very
quick military operation trump
threatened that
he didn't do it so fast interesting
the i andrew the i weekend uh back to
the pandemic
and talking about her over 40s being
able to get the vaccine
in april they're in the next charge
that's right this is the recommendations
by the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization uh what they've
suggested is that those age between 1449
should be prioritized
first followed by people in their 30s
and then concluding with the younger age
group 18-29
of course all of this makes sense there
are lots of factors to consider when it
comes to covert things like underlying
health
issues and obesity uh that can make you
more susceptible to long-term damage
however
it's absolutely clear all of the
evidence is telling us that that age
is the key factor and the younger you
are the less likely it is to have an
effect by the time you're getting into
the 40s and the 30s
um the odds of fatalities are very low
however
uh their right to do it seems very
sensible to me um the reason it's
tendentious
slightly is because a lot of people
would rather that they were
vaccinating people according to
profession so for instance teachers and
online nhs workers and that was being
done but what the committee is saying
is that that presents a particular
logistical challenge because if you're
targeting certain professions
it's a more complex process and that
this might end up
slowing the overall roll out of the
vaccine and that would leave people
uh more vulnerable for longer and
there's a quotation in the article here
from professor
wei shen lim who's the covert chair for
the committee and
who says the current strategy is to
prioritize those who are more likely to
have severe outcomes and die from the
disease
sounds totally sensible for me these are
the experts i think we should let them
get on with what they're doing they seem
to know what they're doing
the government does seem to be on track
it wants to have
all adults vaccinated by the end of july
so there's a lot to be positive about
there's been 19 million vaccines so far
the r number appears to be floating
between 0.6 and 0.9 and that does mean
that the epidemic is shrinking so a lot
to be positive about
yeah although there are some questions
about whether uh teachers in particular
should be vaccinated
um because of the return on march the
8th and it's something that they've said
actually schools they could quite easily
do themselves
but we shall see to the times bedisha
and uh kierstama facing a rebellion
apparently over his
views on his decision actually whether
to um
back a rise in uh corporation tax
yeah this is quite interesting rebellion
sounds like a very strong word
the shadow cabinet uh and kierstama the
labour leader seem to be in slight
opposition because uh he is opposing
projected rises
in corporation tax at the moment and
this is a very
non-traditional labor thing to do
ordinarily labor red labor would be
very much pushing forward for rises in a
corporation tax and not just that but
closing all of the many loopholes which
enable business owners
particularly big business those who
would ordinarily pay a huge amount of
tax
to actually stump up and pay the tax
that they owe instead of sort of
defraying it or passing it off as as
running costs
uh what he's saying is that if there's
an increase in corporation tax at this
time even though the money that's been
spent on covid and whatever else has to
be brought back
is going to put undue pressure on all
sorts of businesses not just the famous
corporations that we all know about and
of course should be paying tax
it's going to put pressure on individual
smaller owned businesses
who are already dealing with a lot of
new brexit red tape
and covert restrictions and wondering
how their businesses
are going to survive many other
shadow cabinet members have spoken out
against his move
and they're in favor not of opposing
what he's doing but of saying okay we
need to look at this
progressively tony blair who i'm not
sure when he speaks of the labour party
i'm not sure it really
helps the labour party that much has
told people to
cut karma cut stammer some slack that's
the freudian slip there karma
[Laughter]
and and to just sort of let this roll
out but
what we do know is that russia sunak is
going to be probably
announcing a staggered corporation tax
rise even going up to 25
but of course we have to wait for the
third of march for sonak to say all of
these things that we're
speculating about yes that is the date
that we are hanging on
to the telegraph andrew and this story
which seems um
quite worrying at first glance is about
foreign doctors prescribing
sex change hormones to 15 year olds in
england
yes so you'll know that back in november
the high court ruled that
uh clinics shouldn't be able to
prescribe puberty blockers to
to young children because they're too
young to consent and there's been a lot
of debates about this
mostly surrounding the tavistock clinic
which is an nhs clinic
that focuses on gender dysphoria in in
young people
this particular study is showing that in
spite of that ruling what is happening
is there are overseas
doctors who are using an online service
called gender gp
and they've admitted to prescribing uh
puberty blockers to children as young as
10
and cross-sex hormones to children as
young as 12 across sex hormones can lead
to
infertility and irreversible changes so
this is actually very conservative
the children without parent consent
because it that's that's right because
it's a legal loophole because it's
it's an online service from overseas and
that's why uh they're able to do it
there's actually a quotation here from
debbie hayton
who is a transgender rights campaigner
and she says for a doctor
to in eastern europe to prescribe a
class iii controlled
drug to a child they have never spoken
to is an egregious breach of protocol
and safeguarding so
we do need to address this it is very
very uh serious however it's also such
an emotive subject and
it strikes me that people are afraid to
have this conversation they really are
they steer clear
because whenever anyone raises concerns
about this they're smeared as
transphobic or hateful i know a lot of
people who have been in this debate
i've never seen any evidence of hate or
anything like it but i know a lot of
people you'll be surprised
who say to me i'm just not getting
involved i have concerns but i'm not
getting involved but actually because of
the sensitivity of the issue
there's more reason for discussion and
debate uh not less
and uh there we need to talk to everyone
we need to consider um
people who who have been through gender
dysphoria who have transitioned
and they've said that it saved their
lives we need to talk to those people we
need to talk to people who have
transitioned and said that it's ruined
their lives people like
kyra bell who's a 23 year old woman who
obviously was involved in the court case
back in november and she said
she had no guidance and she was uh
pressured into taking puberty blockers
when she was too young so
we just need to have the conversation
without all these insults being thrown
back and forth and certainly when it
comes to overseas doctors
finding loopholes to bypass british law
that is something we should be
talking about anyway because obviously
that can't go on yeah no you're
absolutely right it is a conversation
that we need to have
out in the open let's uh end with the
royals one in particular prince harry um
he's been there doing a bit of
rapping this is in the star yes uh and
and not early christmas present either
the other kind the slightly worse kind
uh prince harry has done a very
eye-opening interview on top of a
double-decker bus
riding around los angeles with james
corden it's
uh very off the hook he they stop
outside the mansion at which the fresh
prince of bel air was filmed as any gen
x and knows somehow the theme tune is
like branded into our memory
and of course prince harry wraps it
complete with
hand signals and everything it's weird
uh he faced times with megan who says
that her nickname for him
is has it sounds like a very un-american
way of addressing someone called harry
has or has her um prince harry says that
uh when they put their little baby
archie down tonight
him and him and megan uh just go
upstairs and get a take away and netflix
it out
yes lots being revealed about uh
the royal uh much more to come thank you
both for the moment see you now it's
time